all the immense progress we see around
us was built through convert
conversation and compromise
discussion and debate
voting an inclusion it's an incredible
attestation to the power of democracy to
deliver needs for all the people and now
I know better than most how hard
democracy can be at times
we in the United States have first-hand
experience how fragile even
long-standing Democratic institutions
can be you saw what happened on January
the 6th in my country
we learn Anew with every generation that
democracy needs champions
when I went to college I was a political
science major and history major we used
to every generation has to fight to
preserve democracies
I didn't believe it at the time I just
thought it was automatic
we had this great democracy what would
we need to do
as a friend I hope it's not too
presumptuous for me to say that I
believe Democratic institutions
establishes The Good Friday agreement
remained critical to the future of
Northern Ireland
it's a decision of you to make not for
me to make
but it seems to me they're related
an effective devolved government
that reflects the people of Northern
Ireland
and is accountable to them a government
that works to find ways through hard
problems together
it's going to draw even greater
opportunity in this region
so I hope the assembly and the executive
will soon be restored that's a judgment
for you to make not me but I hope it
happens
along with the institutions that
facilitate north-south and East-West
relations